il y à montplaisir chef de file de la
tendance droite du grand ensemble et
pumba payant chance est avec nous dans
son caddie la doite et karine rousseau
qui ont tapé du poing sur la table on y
reviendra à yan monplaisir mais tout
d'abord une intersyndicale qui pose un
préavis de grève pour dénoncer la
désorganisation les dysfonctionnements
seb la 7e pas de dialogue social des
courriers sans réponse une
infantilisation du personnel climat de
délation 7e d'en haut une 7ème d'en bas
une du sous sol une liste longue comme
le bras yan monplaisir qu'est ce qui ne
tourne pas rond dans cette structure
dont on le rappelle vous êtes vice
président d'abord il faut remettre les
choses en place
si le personnel à travers les centrales
syndicales exprime ma lettre ou malaise
et qu'il y à un mal-être est un mal être
et donc il faut les entendre
ensuite il faut se replacer aussi les
choses dans leur dans leur contexte on
est dans une situation où on met en
place une organisation nouvelle
il y avait deux cultures dont j'allais
dire d'entreprises y avait deux cultures
celle du conseil général et celle du
conseil régional
les problèmes n'ont pas été réglés en
amont comme ils auraient dû l'être
c'est à dire que ceux qui avaient eu
deux ans de prolongation pour régler ces
problèmes là ils ont misé tout cela sous
tapis parce qu'ils ont compris qu'ils
auraient des moments de tension et comme
ils voulaient éviter les moments de
tension avant les élections ils ont dit
on fera ça après pensant qu'ils seraient
réunies il se trouve que c'est nous qui
sommes là aujourd'hui
il y a en plus maintenant se surajoute à
cela certainement certainement je
voudrais dire que ce soit ça le fond du
problème est certainement des raisons
politiques à cela mais dont l'accès aux
visées par les troupes sont en
souffrance yens au plaisir mais comment
peut-on parler d'efficacité dans
l'action que vous voulez mener dans un
tel contexte quatre syndicats quand même
sont mobilisés quatre bouteilles
auraient pu en avoir 10 à partir du
moment où une partie du personnel parce
que ça ne représente qu'une partie du
personnel qu'ils le disent d'ailleurs il
ce qui se passe en ce moment c'est qu'on
est en train de par exemple de nommer
des chefs de service celui qui pensait
qui se serait lui qui seraient nommés et
qui voit que c'est son collègue il est
pas content ouais il ya un peu de ça
aussi
donc il faut il faut pas sous-estimer il
ne faut pas non plus en faire lui dira
le centre du monde
il ya 4000 plus de 4000 personnes qui
fument de stylos d'encre pour les facs
il ya des problèmes de pieds
je s'agit pas vous laisser dire ça je ne
peux pas vous laisser dire ça
précisément le sérieux avec lequel nous
gérons cette collectivité nous permet
d'avoir les moyens de la gérer regard
d'autres collectivités prennent la 7e
temps aux salles de cluny non je parle
de la ctm tout tout cas moi je suis je
suis en bas justement je trouve que mon
bureau et un bail que je n'ai pas de
problème c'est pas votre sous sol on est
tous mais toutes ces satellites tout
c'est maintenant mais non faut pas faut
pas ajouter c'est que je dis non non non
non non je peux pas vous laisser dire ça
mais j'ai vu monsieur viole donc moi ce
n'est pas parce qu'une partie
une partie du personnel vous avez déjà
un blâme au parc naturel régional de
martinique par exemple il y a des
problèmes il y a eu des problèmes il y
aura des problèmes
à partir du moment où orascom il ya des
problèmes dans les entreprises
à partir du moment où vous mettez vous
n'avez pas de problème vous ici en
martinique 1ère et aucun problème tout
va bien quand je passe dans vos couloir
joie que vous affichez c'est bien qu'ils
avaient fort ce que vous faites là yan
monplaisir d'abord de vous et vous
voulez non j'ai pas fait que l'âge d'or
de la vie c'est du jeune âge par dany
coup mais pas de moto je vous parle de
la vie monsieur viol alors la 7e qui
prend l'eau de toutes parts et puisque
quand même le premier tour mais j'ai vu
autant de là vous laisser dire ça
laissez moi vous poser la question mais
quand vous affirmez quand vous affirmez
quelque chose vous vous mettez quelques
chiens nous sommes des témoins de ce qui
se passe le président du conseil
exécutif qui doit faire face à une
contestation sein de sa formation
politique
je ne vois pas ça alfred marie-jeanne
avec l'esprit tourné vers son procès à
venir une connectivité en proie à des
difficultés financières vous l'avez
rappelé la semaine dernière lors des
orientations budgétaires et puis le
pompon le pompon vous il ya mon plaisir
puisque votre formation politique bat
payant chance qui enfonce le clou avec
votre coup de pression lors de ces
orientations budgétaires sur les choix
de la collectivité
vous pouvez me permettre de remettre
tout ça dans l'ordre d'abord je vais te
remettre dans l'ordre d'abord d'abord la
collectivité ne va pas mal et
précisément nous faisons tout pour
qu'elles n'aillent pas mal parce que les
autres collectivités vont mal la plupart
des communes de la martinique sont en
difficulté est là et les pci c'est à
dire des regroupements de communes sont
également en difficulté je rappeler
quelque chose qui vient en contradiction
avec ce que j'ai entendu un peu avant le
rôle de la ctm n'est pas de financer les
autres collectivités ok chaque
collectivité gère ses comptes
c'est vrai que la principale
collectivité c'est la cdm
c'est vrai que il y a des motifs je
dirais des satisfactions il ya il ya il
ya des améliorations qui sont possibles
mais il n'est pas bon il n'est pas bon
pour pour le moral des martiniquais et
et nous avons besoin de ce moment là
pour aller de l'avant
foot-national sortir m bashing est
inexact maintenant c'est parce que je
veux dire oui mais il n'est pas bon de
dire que rien ne va il faut il faut le
vert il peut être à moitié vide ou à
moitié plein et en l'occurrence il ya
des choses qui ne vont pas et quand vous
dites que je dénonce un certain nombre
de choses qui ne vont pas vous avez
raison je le fais d'abord dans un
contexte de responsabilité ses coups de
gueule quand même lorsqu'on vous a dit
que vous n'aurez pas les deux millions
supplémentaires par un vol pour le
comité martiniquais du tourisme
si vous me permettez je le fais dans un
contexte de responsabilités c'est-à-dire
que vous n'entendez pas tout ce que je
dis et heureusement d'ailleurs parce que
j'ai des positions effectivement mais
c'est normal qu'ils sont quelquefois un
peu divergentes par rapport à un autre
groupe ou par rapport au président de
l'exécutif où nous avons des réactions
épidermiques puisqu'il ya quelques mois
déjà vous aviez déjà tu as tu ce n'est
pas évident et même de ne pas voter le
budget au mois d'octobre j'avais indiqué
qu' il me semblait qu'il fallait que
nous corrigions certain nombre d'années
de direction qui avaient été donnés je
continue de le penser
je pense qu'une divergence fondamentale
par exemple je pense que que s'il est
vrai qu'il faut faire en sorte de
redresser les comptes
parce que nous avons trouvé une
situation difficile parce que l'état
veut que les collectivités fassent des
économies et donc on est dans un
contexte qui est contraignant pour
autant pour autant ce que je ne veux pas
ce que je ne souhaite pas et je suis à l
écoute d une entreprise sur l écoute des
chefs d'entreprise je suis à l'écouté du
monde économique
celui qui crée l'activité celui qui
donne le travail dans la baie de celui
qui assure le développement
et bien ce monde économique il nous dit
il ne faut pas que vous ferez n'y ait
trop brutalement le rythme alors
d'investissement alors yan monplaisir
ça fait un petit peu brutus et son coup
de poignard dans le dos de césar
connaissant ce contexte hausse est de la
ctm on va le rappeler des factures que
vous vous dites que vous découvrez
encore peu de finance de nouvelles
règles dans la gestion des finances des
collectivités le risque de sanctions
l'autre si on ne reste pas dans les
clous est ce que quelque part
vous ne la joue et pas du tout un
collectif pas du tout je suis très
collectif je suis loyal je ne suis pas
dans la théorie du complot ni dans le
complot par contre jean temps nous avons
fait un contrat j'entends que ce contrat
soit respecté
d'abord il me faut les informations un
audit a été diligentée commandes et
payés par la collectivité
le président de l'exécutif à cet audit
en main je souhaite la voie là vous êtes
sur la même ligne que ensemble pour une
martinique nouvelle qui demande plus de
transparence dans un certain nombre de
documents
oui si vous voulez cg on peut qui vous
applaudissent à jeudi dernier sait très
bien qu'il me le dise moi vous savez ce
qui m'intéresse c'est l'intérêt de la
martinique et moi j'ai besoin
j'ai besoin je suis pas un idiot je suis
pas plus bêtes que qui que ce soit et
les autres élus non plus et nous avons
besoin d informations donc par exemple
là nous on a une divergence et là j'ai
dit au président je ne suis pas d'accord
et c'est légitime dans la main comme ça
ça fait pas un peu la bête déjà par
tiers qu'il faut achever dans ce
contexte et alors alors cette question
là je me la suis posée mais ça c'est pas
mon problème ce n'est pas moi qui a
allumé je dirais la contestation à
l'intérieur de l'autre partie de la
majorité
chacun est vrai que ces problèmes de son
côté nous avons nos problèmes ils ont
les leurs bon chacun avec ses problèmes
est-ce qu'à partir de ça je dois me
sentir paralysé menou tsk partir de soi
jeu de ça je dois dire ben dans le
contexte compliqué de mon allié et jeux
et j'en tiens compte et j'en tiens
compte et je je fais en sorte de ne pas
aller au delà de ce qui pourrait
effectivement poser problème mais je ne
peux pas en mon âme et conscience j'ai
été ému par les martiniquais
ils m'ont fait confiance ils nous ont
dit nous voulons de ce rassemblement
parce que nous voulons mettre fin à une
forme de j'allais dire de dictature oui
on d'autorité excessive et exclusive
nous avons fait une alliance une
alliance démocratique
je suis partie de cette alliance le
contrat est définie il faut que ce
contrat il se rend il soit remplie il
faut qu'on délègue très bien comment
vous vous entraînez vous milhas de
montplaisir avec miguel laventure qui
quand même le conseil exécutif en charge
des finances issu de votre famille
politique et qui s'aligne sur la même
longueur d'onde qu'elle ferait de
marie-jeanne on dit même que
c'est le meilleur avocat d'alfred
marie-jeanne miguel laventure je pense
qu'il est il remplit bien sa mission
je pense que on lui demande de faire un
job et qu'il le fait avec mais ça je
dirais que avec brio avec maestria
il le fait bien il le fait bien la fête
bien mais il était bien la même chose
que vous c'est à dire ben concernant ce
que nous devons faire pour ses os et de
7 cm pour le développement je crois que
je crois pour avoir parlé avec lui
longuement qu'il pense la même chose que
moi
cela étant il est il fait un job il
il rend compte qu'ils rapportent et donc
ils rapportent comme on lui demande de
rapporter pour autant pour autant quelle
que soit la porte comme on lui demande
de rapporter cette fidèle soldat
ce fidèle soldat mais c'est son job on
sait sa fonction c'est sa mission s'il
ne un moment donné il va il peut se
trouver dans une contradiction c'est à
lui et à sa conscience
je dirais de juger personnellement je le
dis pour que ce soit bien clair je suis
dans une alliance avec le grand ensemble
et qui est conduit par alfred marie
jeanne
je suis très heureux d'être dans cette
alliance parce que nous avons évité une
catastrophe à la martinique
je suis très heureux qu'elle ferait de
marie-jeanne soit à la fois courageux et
en même temps déterminée à redresser
pour autant je ne peux pas être d'accord
complètement avec lui je souhaite qu'il
y ait plus de transparence qu'il y ait
plus de dialogue qu'il y ait plus d
coûte et qu'on ne freine pas trop
brutalement la machine économique
parce que ça aurait des conséquences
graves pour la martine ça s'appelle le
gros sectarian au plaisir non ça
s'appelle tout simplement la lucidité
ça s'appelle le respect des lecteurs et
ça s'appelle tout simplement rempliront
contrat vis-à-vis dam de la majorité et
vis-à-vis des électeurs martiniquais
merci d'avoir été ce matin avec nos yan
monplaisir rappelle que vous êtes vice
président de l'assemblée de martinique
également chef de file de ba payant
chance la tendance droite du grand
ensemble hip hop et en chansons bonne
journée merci
[Musique]